este sábado olímpico terminó de manera
espectacular con la final femenil de los
100 metros planos y el 123 de jamaica
fue elaine thompson quien se colgó el
oro y además con un récord olímpico de
10 segundos 61 centésimas su compatriota
julie ann fraser pryce se quedó con la
plata y sérika jackson con el bronce fue
una jornada también muy interesante en
medallas para francia que ya suma 19 en
esta participación aquí en a tokio hoy
ganó una en oro muy especial en judo por
equipos
ganándole además a japón que ha sido el
gran dominante en este deporte en estas
competiciones y bueno en natación
también estuvo quedado expresa del
norteamericano que se colgó su tercer
oro esta vez fue en 100 metros o
mariposa además lo hizo con un récord
mundial de 49.95 el único que ha podido
estar por debajo de los 50 segundos no
hay que perderle de vista mañana porque
va a participar en los 50 metros libres
y allí puede que haya un excelente y muy
entretenido duelo contra
flojo a menudo el francés y por último
mañana habrá las finales de gimnasia
tanto de salto como de barras
asimétricas y bueno simón varios no
participará ella continúe en ese proceso
en el que está cuidando mucho su salud
mental y su salud física basta esperar
si va a participar o no en los dos
finales que aún le quedan pendientes